I heard you love Fabian I didn't fail my
sister love Fabian back in the day you
were in the Fabian fan club what tell
your sister I was I was the president of
the Fabian saying that now in light of
history I was so young and he was so
cute yes yes yes but of the Beatles it
was Paul it was always Paul yeah what
you know what to me those guys they
taught me more than anyone and still do
they do I mean you put on White Album
you listen to that you learn something
every time it's unreal it is unreal
I was just thinking of a John Lennon
lyric yeah but Danny went oh that's what
he meant I'm just starting to get it
yeah Hey Jude I mean think about it all
of it all I mean I find his I find their
music to be so not just a part of my
past like like I have a lot of music
that's part of my past this is I passed
my present my future were you a rock fan
I was yeah you wouldn't go to a Zeppelin
concert though would you
no I didn't ever I didn't but I went to
the first Rolling Stones concert that
ever came to Chicago back in the early
you know to mid 60's
are they the world's greatest rock and
roll but they're amazing they are they
are amazing because of the amount of
material that this band put out yeah and
look they're staying power their stamina
it's inspirational people like how is he
alive that's the more interesting
question yeah I mean there's something
to investigate but his book was
brilliant peeps
oh god yes how do the Rolling Stones
stay together after Keith slaughtered a
Mick Jagger in that book Mick is a
really pragmatic guy do you know Mick I
do I never met him
where do you meet Mick oh gosh I've met
I I met him first probably in the White
House
I don't came to see you when you're in
the White House you can invite anybody
to come see you what do you say to these
people do you fan out over them or my
mother loved the Rolling Stones that's
that's progress
oh the Rolling Stones were at the Beacon
Theater I think it was a Scorsese
filming so we were invited I brought my
mother I thought she was gonna pass out
and you know her favorite was Keith
Richards
oh yeah so because my mother loved Keith
Richards we asked if he would call her
on her birthday and he did it was like
the best birthday she ever had the fact
that Mick Jagger could be in a band with
this guy who now bad-mouths him it'd be
like if you hung out with Trump after
all the things right that would be hard
but he treats Mick like he's Trump well
but they've been together for so long
and I think I don't know I think they
understand each other unbelievable